a long long time ago I wrote an
assembler those app codes used to make
me smile I wrote my hello world program
in 16 kilobytes of RAM no function calls
no to before or while I'd said I'll
nights and rap frustration trying new
optimizations forgot to sleep or eat I
would not admit defeat every change
caused more confusion surrounded by my
old illusion finally came to a
conclusion I do a big rain it's high
time we were viewed a design
could be either system is just too
Byzantine will rewrite all the legacy
and take it offline and it's gonna
compile first time it's gonna compile
first time
[Music]
20
it's well
who did you started
[Music]
[ __ ]
well it's not like you
we are got started
Borden's me
listings
see
those games a key bite
convinced our coos table
to
hi
but go behind a system most is too bad
your time will rewrite all the legacy
and take it offline it's gonna compile
first time it's first time
[Music]
it's not
[Music]
it was a different age to Pascal
well 640k of the memory should be enough
Reni
multitask
[Music]
with you baby
- norton's ms Tuscany
[Music]
go behind the system misters to my tent
I will be right over
[Music]
first time it's gonna compare first time
[Music]
just
what's the promise
go to HTML
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
could be an assistant mistress to
lighten time
take it offline it's gonna compile first
time it's gonna pull our first time
and then we were shouting and
to the lab and post it up
elastic scale the code
infrastructure
sure
[Music]
well I said now watch the counters climb
washing I got paid overtime but mongodb
fairly I guess it was scale
with last hole available in zone
I couldn't get tech support on the phone
that's the point when I was shy
[Music]
Coby hider system is just to buy said
time lutely right all AC and take apply
[Music]
it's gonna compile first time
I did my time paid my dues I did my exit
interviews turned around and walked away
tired of working for the man I had a
dream I had a plan this time I do
everything my way
launched the perfect MEP online for all
the world to see working style
fast and lean and agile attract all my
feature requests I broke my code with
unit tests and one day no rest I did
agree
[Music]
it's time we reviewed I decide the code
behind our system is just two byes and
time will rewrite all this legacy take
it offline it's gonna compile the first
time it's gonna compile first time
we were singing had time we reviewed a
design the code behind our system is
just to buy Zinta will rewrite all the
legacy and take it of land it's gonna
compile first time something's coming
[Music]
maybe it's Moriarty maybe it's not
[Music]
come on let's finish this the way we
started together
[Music]
I was raised to do one thing
I've got nothing to fight for take a
seat
[Music]
I've lived for over two thousand years
not all of them were good I've made many
mistakes
[Music]
it's about time that I did something
about that
[Music]
good morning and DC how're you doing
how are the party hangovers I've agreed
to postpone mine until after lunch
welcome to learning to love legacy code
my name is dylan bt i am a CTO at a
company here in london called skills
matter I run a dotnet user group I have
been building code and running websites
and applications on the internet since
1992 basically ancient history in
internet years and I spent a good part
of my career from 2003 until at the
beginning of last year working for these
people spotlight the home of casting
spotlight is often described as the
linkedin factors it is the tool and the
platform that is used by Lucasfilm the
BBC the Royal Shakespeare Company the
people who make all of those shows and
movies that we just saw in that intro
sequence there to find the actors who
they place in those films
that's how films get cast casting as
part of how films get made now how many
of you have seen Star Wars the last Jedi
how many of you liked it how many of you
didn't like it how many of you didn't
like it because they used classic ASP to
find the actors you know yeah that's not
why you didn't like it the things about
it you didn't like that code that I
created in 2003 some of it that is still
running in the tools that are still
being used to make those movies and
those TV shows it is part of a journey
that exists to produce a product and we
don't care about the code as consumers
the journey that exists there is about
making movies and making TV shows and
putting on plays and that kind of thing
and the legacy nurse of the code is kind
of irrelevant to that so that's you know
one of the things I want to talk you
about today I was at spotlight for 15
years I literally joined as webmaster I
built 1.0 I hired the team who built 2.0
I'm entered the team who built 3.0 I was
the architect
3.5 and I occasionally go for the beers
with the people who are still trying to
ship 4.0 which is engaging but I kind of
I've seen this one codebase evolve over
literally 15 years and had that
experience where we get some some
contractors or some new developers and
they look at a piece of code they're
like this is a piece of crap the person
who wrote it was clearly insane who let
them near a keyboard and because I have
that historical context you can sit down
and go right let me explain what it was
like the day we wrote this these things
didn't exist Stack Overflow didn't exist
these things still happened we still
made books how would you have solved the
problem and they kind of go yeah maybe
they weren't insane after all you know
so that's one of the things I want to
talk about is a perspective on legacy
code bases from somebody who literally
worked on a code base for so long it
became legacy while I was still working
on it the other thing that I want to
talk about is the rate of change that
exists in software and in technology
this is an iPhone this is just over ten
years old 2007 this is an iPhone one now
even if you could find one of these and
you could find the right kind of cable
and you could plug it in and you found
one where the battery was still working
if you booted this thing up it is it's
basically useless because this phone is
part of a or was part of this huge
connected network of platforms and tools
and services and applications and
protocols most of which do not exist
anymore they have been upgraded you can
get this thing up to about I think iOS
version 5 was the highest upgrade for
the original iPhone 1 and you can't run
modern twitter or whatsapp or snapchat
or anything on iOS version 5 they just
don't work you have to find a 7 year old
version of Twitter which will go and
point not found it just doesn't work the
entire industry within 10 years has
turned upside down so dramatically that
the beautiful irony is the only things
that this thing will do today are make
phone calls and send text messages you
know it's still a phone because that
hasn't changed
now if you went at this this retailed
for what about $800 when it first came
out about six seven hundred pounds and
if you had gone out the day the iPhone
one was released
you had bought a washer/dryer or you'd
bought a guitar or you'd bought like a
hammer drill or something that would
still work you'd still have that in your
house and it would probably still be
going strong you know but we've just
kind of got used to this idea that
mobile phones get replaced every 18
months because that's what everyone
wants us to think and besides that means
they don't have to work out how to make
batteries that lasts more than two or
three years now with the mobile phone
industry they have so much money and so
much influence and such a powerful
marketing machine that will just kind of
roll with it
well I a new phone now 18 months time
for an upgrade the organizations that we
work in the bespoke code bases that we
run we don't have that option because we
are not dripping in billions and
billions of dollars of cellphone revenue
we have to maintain the stuff that we
build for awhile for a long long time
let's take a little nostalgic trip
[Music]
[Music]
is anyone enough for friends friend they
tell me which season that's the opening
for season eight 2003 so that was airing
that was the biggest rating show on
British TV in the year when I wrote the
code that they used a couple years back
to make Star Wars and Doctor Who and a
lot of stuff and it's still running it's
still there in production it's written
in JavaScript it's written in classic
ASP it is legacy code now you know we
all agree that legacy code exists right
you all come to a talk about it clearly
you think it's a thing and you can get
books about it and you can go on
training courses about it but why
wouldn't we talk about legacy code what
do we actually mean here's some code I
want to get Tommy but on a scale of one
to ten how legacy is this I mean we got
this this for some reason we run out of
memory without this surely they'd have
fixed that by now right
you know this must be pretty but it's
hard to tell you can't just look at a
piece of code and go is this legacy code
or not you know and so I've actually
I've invented this this is the legacy
code ometer and and what you do is you
stick it up on your desk with some vodka
and you plug the USB port here into the
back of your laptop and every time you
open a file in Visual Studio vs code
whatever it tells you from zero to 20
how legacy the code is so you know what
it is that you're dealing with here
right yeah that's gonna solve the
problem is it this piece of code would
this for some reason we ran out of
memory without this eeeek was shipped by
John skeet yesterday this is a bug fix
and the latest version of Notre time
this is not legacy code but the point is
you cannot look at the code
legacy nurse is not a property of lines
of code code is just code it's the same
code that it was when it was written
wherever it was written by whoever wrote
it in the first place so we need to
understand what it is what what is this
actual situation we talk about when we
talk about something like a legacy code
base so if we go on Wikipedia and we
look up legacy code we get this you know
source code that relates to a no longer
supported citation needed or
manufactured operating system and then
it says the term was first used by
computer scientist George Olivetti and
then there is this little
vacation and the citation links to this
article here Sam Mullen legacy is not a
bad word which says legacy code the term
was first used by computer scientist
George Olivetti Wikipedia I've never
heard of George Olivetti nobody has ever
heard of George Olivetti there was an
Olivet C computer company but as far as
we know it wasn't started by a guy
called George and it's George here is
mr. Olivetti in the room somewhere today
you know and so this is not a terribly
helpful definition because it's just
Wikipedia citing its own thing and there
is a very famous definition from a this
guy Michael feathers who literally wrote
the book he's been working with legacy
code for years he does fantastic
training and you know presentations and
books about it legacy code to him is
simply code without tests now I think
this is the truth but I do not think
this is the whole truth
I agree exactly with what he says but I
think there is more to it than that and
there's a definition that I've been
using in meetings for a while now legacy
code is code that's too scary to update
and too profitable to delete that's why
it's still there if nobody's using it
yeah delete it get rid of it that's not
legacy we just cleaned up it's gone you
know legacy code bases other things
where we are wary of changing them we
are afraid to modify things because we
don't know what's going to happen there
is a risk associated with it but at the
same time rightly or wrongly we believe
that it is necessary and you know legacy
code in a lot of industries it's code
that makes money that's why it exists
when you're Greenfield and you have no
customers your code base is pure and
beautiful and elegant and the day after
you ship and somebody says yeah we'll
give you $5,000 if you do this that's
when the legacy starts because at that
point you have something you can't
change otherwise they're gonna take that
$5,000 away or fifty thousand or five
hundred thousand or however much um now
the first time I gave this talk there
was a someone tweeted this slide and
somebody sort of called it out and said
I think very something very similar from
JB rains Berger who's another very very
smart person who works on similar things
um now we I believe came up with this
quote independently but I wasn't the
first person to do it very profitable
code that we are afraid to
change so there seems to be this sort of
some kind of consensus now let's talk
about that idea of afraid to change what
is it that is scary about it and the
thing that scary about it is the unknown
one of the oldest business practices
that exists anywhere in the world does
anyone tell me what this is double entry
bookkeeping when you are working at how
much money your company has you know
income and outgoings expenditure capital
revenue all these kinds of things you do
everything twice every transaction gets
recorded in two places and then at the
end of the day you add up everything in
this side and everything in this side
and the numbers should be the same if
the numbers are not the same there is a
mistake somewhere something's gone
missing you've carried a one that you
shouldn't have carried there's been an
error something's gone missing someone
is sneaking money out of the till it
gives you two points of reference
now that is I think you know Michael
feathers quote about code without tests
a code base with unit tests the
decisions about what that code should do
are reflected in two places there is the
code and then there is the test which
says is the code doing what we think it
does the double-entry bookkeeping this
is what happened and this is our double
check did what we think happened
actually happened now often in the kind
of early days particularly on on small
projects or where you've got a very very
small team of developers there are still
two sources of truth about what the code
is supposed to do have you seen this why
you shouldn't interrupt a programmer so
if C equals come a backtrack one and
then and I'm sure you can all relate to
this you get this little process so we
set a backtrack and this to happen then
this happens and this happens in you and
you've got this this elaborate kind of
mental crystal thing floating in your
mind and then someone comes there a hey
I sent you an email about the thing you
wanna sign Gina's birthday card did you
get cake shall we have coffee did you
see TV and boom and you're like okay if
C equals comma metric we have this in a
lot of projects our concept of the
solution exists in two places one is in
the code the other one is in your head
and this when you
that thing where somebody looks at a
line of code and they're like oh yeah
that's wrong that's what's happening up
does this is the fastest documentation
anyone has ever invented this is faster
than Wikipedia faster than the manual
faster than Stack Overflow it is the
mental model that is hovering there just
behind your eyes while you look at the
code and when you are working on a you
know a kind of single developer just
cranking out code one of those massively
productive things where you kind of not
worry too much about what the rest of
the team does and you haven't written
any documentation and stuff what you're
doing is you are closing the gap between
your mental model and the code that is
on the screen in these very very very
rapid feedback loops
you know sometimes not even waiting for
unit tests you type something you look
at it like that's not going to work
backtrack typing again backtrack time to
get back bang back right I think this is
probably good done compile grab a coffee
go back to it and this is fun you know
this is a really really not it's fun
there's also studies that show this
actually releases dopamine this this
rapid feedback problem-solving process
it's addictive the same way that
gambling and cocaine are addictive you
can get hooked on doing this and it's
one of the few addictions you can get
paid for being good at which puts us in
a slightly weird position as as
professional developers you know there
is a fantastic talk Jessica Kerr
Jessa Tron does and that's something
called samatha sysm and I want to borrow
one of her slides for this bit because
one of her observations in there is that
the process of invention making new
things feels like going downhill it is
this kind of smooth easy creative fun
process analysis where you're looking at
something that already exists and trying
to understand it is the other direction
downhill invention uphill analysis
writing code is easy and fun and fast
reading code is difficult and slow and
you know often it's nothing like as much
fun of sitting you know cranking out
lines and methods and routines we all
know this you know at least I hope we
all knows someone in here who hates
being a programmer and that just boss
sent them here we can talk afterwards
and then I'll butter Brandolini came up
with this fantastic post about something
called the dungeon master and the
dungeon master is the person who has the
documentation for version 1 in their
head they are probably the person who
wrote
the first version of the system they are
the person who everyone is frightened
they are going to leave and it's a
really really good post go and look it
up and what he's doing is he's talking
about patterns you can use when you find
yourself in this situation you have the
dungeon master who wrote version 1 and
now you're like this isn't working this
person has become a critical dependency
we can't scale we can't paralyze we
can't outsource what do we do about it
and here's Flor some of the options do
you make though the dungeon master the
product owner do you make the dungeon
master the tech lead do you put them in
a clean room and just pay them to keep
quiet while you you do a real
implementation of of what they've done
but you know this is a situation that we
find us often and it's easier to say
that something like NDC well obviously
you know we don't do that anymore
because we have pair programming and we
have agile and we have scrum and you
know we have all of these really really
good onion I do believe they are good
these patterns and practices we've
learned that running your entire company
on a code base with no documentation
except what's in one person's head is
maybe not the best way of building
sustainable businesses right but we are
not talking about the code we are gonna
write on Monday or the code we're gonna
write next year or the project that
we're gonna start in the fall we are
talking about code that already exists
and that code about this much of it is
serverless f-sharp micro services you
know new and shiny they can't possibly
go wrong because the server lists and
their f shop and their microservices you
know and then we've got asp.net with
some tests you know where somebody had a
couple of weeks where they put unit
tests on things Visual Basic 6 on
Windows XP runs more of the world than
you credit anybody who got here today on
a train or an airplane or a bus probably
somebody used a vb6 application at some
point in allocating you that ticket that
got you to this venue and then there is
the code that actually runs the world
which is Excel spreadsheets it really is
you know um fill-in Herrmann's has this
great talk about how Excel is the
world's most popular functional
programming language because it is you
know Excel has no side effects you have
to build a declarative model where each
cell can only reference every other cell
but so much of the world we live in runs
on little home-brewed excel spreadsheets
you know built by people who would never
call themselves developers
but they've worked out how to use a
machine to solve problems and make their
lives easier and stuff and and so you
know how do we how do we end up with
this how do we get to a point where all
this stuff down here is running the
world but we're not interested in that
nobody here wants to work on Excel
spreadsheets we want to be doing this
stuff and you know maybe the stuffin and
you know going and doing rust and go and
all of these kind of cutting-edge
JavaScript progressive web application
mobile xamarin that's the kind of stuff
you come to MDC to learn about you know
not not Excel spreadsheets why I think a
big part of it is fashion you know it's
way human we want to be like doing new
exciting things we want to feel like
we're part of a tribe we want to feel
like we're you know up-to-date with
what's going on we don't want to feel
like we're getting left behind or
isolated or anything and you know I a
big factor in this for me is the
relationship that the technology
industry has with recruitment because
I've talked to people you know that
spotlight how people leave the team or
like I'm not learning anything here I'm
like you're kidding you're learning how
they make Star Wars they're like yeah
but I'm worried that if I don't know
angular I'm gonna become unemployable
and you know you have this this person
on the left here they got the resume
three months of angular six months of
blazer three days of web assembly four
weeks of Russ two weeks of Kotlin ten
minutes of album and this person here
c-sharp sequel HTML you know and this is
the message that people are getting now
you know I'm not saying here I think
people are mercenary one of the most
important factors in whether you feel
comfortable and safe and you enjoy
you're in life is you're not worrying
about stuff you're not worrying about
security you're not worrying about if I
lose my job will I be able to pay my
bills you know feed my kids go on
holidays and this plays into that in a
big way people want to feel like if
whatever you're doing right now doesn't
work out it's gonna be easy enough to
walk into another role and we keep
sending this message that you have to
stay up to date now there are very few
real important problems in the world
that you could not solve with c-sharp
sequel in HTML if you had to you know
that gives you behavior it gives you
presentation it gives you storage those
are the three kind of fundamental
propositions of one humans computing
level
but this person here you know runs like
are there a dinosaur you know they still
think hTML is a good idea like don't
they know about angular reactive UJS
webpack bower maven note grunt gulp did
I miss any so I want to explore that
idea about you know fear and why we are
afraid of getting left behind and afraid
of making changes to legacy systems here
is the path to the dark side fear leads
to anger anger leads to hate hate leads
to suffering
you know what suffering leads to
JavaScript to me fear is about a lack of
three things confidence the opposite to
me a fear is not courage it is
confidence and confidence is
understanding trust and control now the
hardest of these things is trust we have
this expression and we're talking it do
you trust these systems you're working
on do you trust the hosting provider do
you trust your colleagues do you trust
the people making decisions there are
all these factors if you trust
everything cool headphones on and you
get on with what you're doing if you are
constantly shipping code and anyone here
have those unit tests that just like
fail one time in three and you dunno why
and so whenever you get a failing test
you'll like it probably wasn't me you
know let me run it again and go and get
a coffee and come back and like Oh third
time lucky run it again you know and you
don't have trust there you're having to
check and double-check and triple-check
these these are odds if you have a
rock-solid test suite you like Allred I
did something bad let me fix it back
don't ship it it's all green we're
literally gonna press deploy and leave
the building and we're gonna be over the
street having beers by the time the code
goes to production because we trust the
process that much you know and and Trust
is is wonderful but Trust is the
expression is built in drops and lost in
buckets I have this laptop here that
I've been using for the last three or
four years to do these kinds of events
and it has such would never blown up on
me yeah now if it crashes on stage once
I would be like useless piece of crap
those four years you know day one it's
like new laptop I'm not sure about this
day - okay day three four five first
couple of weeks like this is pretty good
first couple of months you're like okay
now I trust it now it's like don't leave
home without it but all it takes is one
you know
catastrophic unexplained fare
you're like well there we go we're back
to square one the trust is gone you got
to start rebuilding it and this is true
of you know like I said people hardware
networks all of the dependencies that
you rely on to be part of a team that's
shipping stuff people are gonna use I
don't have a magic bullet for that I
have no answer for trusts you know it
takes just build it over time
let's talk about understanding and
control now one of the biggest things
that we find in our industry is how do
you how do we train people to be good at
their job not just you know good at the
wider sphere of how do you develop
software but how do you add features to
a particular code base or work on a
particular project now anyone here have
it like a computing science degree like
you've been in actually sat in a room
for three years and learned how to be a
scientist who does computing you know
because I did this I have a three I did
a three-year undergraduate at the
University of Southampton which is one
of the best computer science and
electronics universities in the UK and
we just learned like year one we built
little programs in a whole variety of
things I built little programs in Lisp
and little programs in Java and then in
second year I built little programs in
orc and said and Prolog and all these
and the third year I built and one of
the cool things about Lisp is you can
build little programs that actually do
quite a lot of stuff we built a lisp
interpreter in Java but these were still
you know there was nothing in my entire
undergraduate thing which I couldn't if
I needed to
yes in redbull and doing a weekend you
know it taught me a lot about algorithms
and data structures but fundamentally it
feels to me a bit like this you got to
you know building school and and you
know one they're like we are going to
build wooden sheds we're gonna teach you
all of the techniques necessary to
create wooden sheds and second you know
they're like metal sheds and third you
have the really advanced class glass
sheds and you're like that's it I'm
qualified I'm a building architect now I
know how to do things and you walk out
into your first jobs like hey I'm a
developer and they say we need one of
these
and you're like I got this you know
because we don't teach you know the
classical computer science education is
not about teaching someone how to dive
headfirst into a quarter of a million
lines of visual basic code and make any
sense of it you know they teach data
structures and algorithms and one of the
things that university did for me really
well is it taught me to learn things in
a hurry and then forget them quickly
when I was finished which is a very
valuable skill so you know we're not
coming out of school with the skills we
need to go and work on your company's
massive monolithic legacy code base so
what we do is we hire people and on day
one we sit them down oh yeah right take
a couple of days to read through the
code and one read these all of them in
order anyone now how many words there
are in the complete Harry Potter just
over a million and these hardback
editions the average about eight nine
lines so we're talking somewhere between
100 and 120 thousand lines in the
complete Harry Potter system yeah 120
thousand lines now let's do a little
comparative analysis here I'm gonna put
some stuff up on here so this is Hamlet
this Moby Dick the brothers cameras of
the Lord of the Rings Atlas Shrugged war
and peace this is number of lines the
Linux kernel and mano now what's wrong
with this graph there's no numbers I am
lying to you with statistics because
this is a logarithmic scale on a linear
scale
it looks like this now the Linux kernel
is generally celebrated as being a
relatively tight cohesive small project
in terms of the complexity of the code
it is widely understood it is widely
documented it is kind of they had this
very very minimalist approach don't put
crap in the kernel put that elsewhere on
the system so the Linux kernel is a
pretty good example of a small codebase
the Linux kernel is bigger than war and
peace' Atlas Shrugged Lord of the Rings
and the complete Harry Potter all put
together and that's small you know it's
about a hundred hundred twenty thousand
lines so saying to someone read the
codebase it's like bringing them in on
the first day going read all of these
books give them a couple of days then
you come in on day three and you're like
yeah we need you to make it change to
scope you're like what's the change you
know Hedwig we're gonna make Hedwig a
pig
tell us what's gonna break and all right
okay you're thinking okay so there's a
bit of pager Hedwig flew through the
window yeah that's not gonna work you
know and but to work confidently on a
codebase where you don't have tests and
you don't have documentation and you
don't have you know integration and
monitoring stuff it's exactly like that
it's like someone giving you three days
to read all the Harry Potter and then
saying well you want to change Hedwig
into a pig give us a list of everything
that's going to break and go and fix
them or you know this idea of you read
it
and after you read it you understand it
and then when you understand it you can
work with confidence I just don't think
it's realistic on code bases of any
substantial size we need a better way of
understanding things than reading
richard fineman one of my sort of
personal great heroes I love the way he
approached science and the study and the
teaching of science and he won the Nobel
Prize for Physics for creating something
called Feynman diagrams
he wrote a corollary to the
investigation into the space shuttle
Challenger explosion which NASA refused
to publish officially because it said a
lot of nasty things about them that no
one else was prepared to say but during
the 1960's the government of Brazil
approached Fineman and they said we want
to teach science in our schools better
we don't know what's going on all of our
kids in our Brazilian high schools are
getting great grades in science but then
none of them are getting jobs in science
none of them is working in laboratory
we have no innovation and so for a
couple years Feynman would go down for a
you know a couple of months every year
and any gutter carnivals and he played
bongos and he would talk to teachers and
educators and his planning he came back
to that you know the Brazilian Board of
Education he said the problem you've got
is you're teaching your kids the answers
to the exams you're not teaching them
anything about science said I said them
in front of a roomful of kids and I say
what is the name of the phenomenon that
is exhibited when a crystal is deformed
under pressure and they all put their
hand up and they say scintillation or
triboluminescence and then I say to them
you ever go home and go in the closet
close the doors and crush a sugar cube
with a pair of pliers and none of them
has ever done that you know none of
these kids has any idea that the
phenomenon we are talking about is when
you crush sugar in a dark closet where
the power players you get blue sparks
they just know that if they see these
words and the question they get these
words and the answer they are learning
by rote they are not actually learning
by doing they are not developing any
understanding because they are not doing
experiments now I am a big fan of
something we call the scientific method
this is the basis of pretty much all
experimental science you begin with an
observation you look at something you
think all right let's not mess anything
up yet or just you know stare at it for
a couple of days and see what it does
and you formulate a hypothesis hmm this
we keep getting this error message crop
up in our log files I think that error
message might be because one of the
database columns is not wide enough for
the user agent strings that modern
browsers are sending to our platform you
design a prediction you say I think if
we increase this column to 256
characters we will stop getting out of
range errors from web visitors visiting
our site you conduct an experiment how
can I validate whether my prediction was
correct or not you analyze your findings
you know maybe you do this in a sandbox
environment maybe you do it in
production maybe that you do with some
kind of simulation you communicate maybe
you write a blog post tell the rest of
your team share it send an email say to
people hey you know I I noticed this I
thought it might be this design the
experiment I ran the experiment looked
at the results here's what I found and
often what comes out of the analysis
is you modify your hypothesis hmm it's
not the width of the field maybe we're
getting extended Unicode characters in
browser user agent strings coming from
somewhere let's see if we change it from
being a voucher to a Unicode character
maybe that will fix the problem you go
round and round this cycle now the
problem with science as a software
engineering technique is that at this
point and this point in this point in
this point and pretty much all the way
around this loop until you solve the
problem you have no idea what you're
doing
you are like 250,000 lines of Visual
Basic and well let's put this bit and
see what this does and so to be able to
use this as any kind of effective
technique for working on code we need
ways that we can run that code without
breaking anything
we need sandbox environments now how
many of you have ever taken a codebase
that you're working on do you know you
know get clone or whatever or subversion
checkout or visual sourcesafe or
whatever you're stuck working with put
it on your laptop switched off the Wi-Fi
and run it how far does it get yeah
because a lot of the systems we build
now they used to be a day when you could
check out the code you could press run
and there was a little console
application or your WinForms application
but what we tend to build now are
components of distributed systems that
talk to other services they talk to
databases they send emails they pull in
stock ticket prices and weather reports
and all kinds of stuff it is very very
difficult to run most and when I say
modern here I'm talking about stuff that
was cutting-edge 10 years ago and now we
don't know how to switch it off that
kind of modern you know kind of first
wave of distributed systems engineering
which is now very very prevalent in a
lot of organizations it is hard to run
those things in a sandbox and understand
what they do but there are techniques
you can use to do it you know get a
local copy of the database that's step
one if you have services it something
like we can't run that service locally
something that I've done many times is
I've literally gone into my hosts file
and I've said right I'm gonna run this
thing with a network track or I'm gonna
see every single address it's connecting
to then I'm gonna use hosts to point all
of those local hosts and I'm gonna run
something on local hosts that just tells
me what requests are coming in and it is
amazing how
often you can effectively simulate an
entire so the API like a payments API
gateway most of the time for what you're
doing well you need is it to send back
ok if you're just testing something else
that at some point requires a payment to
be acknowledged put a JSON file that
says ok in a folder and expose that over
HTTP using a loop local loopback server
your code makes a quirk West gets a
response you keep on doing what they're
doing
you can systematically isolate the
components of the system you're working
on now I'm gonna put a very explicit
caveat in here if you're working with
message queues be really really really
careful because a message queue will
quite happily go oh there's no Wi-Fi all
right I'll put them over here and then
you get back in the office and you
switch the Wi-Fi on and it's like I got
a thousand customer emails I'm gonna
send now test test test test test test
test test test and you know if it's
misconfigured it can feed those into a
real system which goes all email so yeah
I know how to send those and send them
so if you're working with real time
synchronous systems if it failed on a
plane you're probably alright if you're
working with any kind of asynchronous or
message queuing system be a little bit
more careful like it very least when you
switch it back on look at what's coming
out of the network on that but you can
reach a point where you have your code
running in a sandbox it's up on a
workbench it's in the laboratory you can
start experimenting with it now the next
thing you have the scientific method you
have a hypothesis you have a prediction
you have an experiment you need a way of
getting your changes shipped you need a
way of getting that the stuff you've
done through into production in a way
that you trust in a way that is reliable
and reproducible and this is where we
get into this idea of continuous
deployment now I've worked on projects
I'm sure you all have where the
deployment process is you put the right
dll's in the right folder on the right
day and then you send the right email to
the right person who copies the right
delouse from that folder to the other
folder on the other server and if anyone
you know makes a typos and misses
something or skips a step or is off sick
that day the process doesn't work and so
you don't do it very often and because
you don't do it very often it gets scary
because no one can remember what
happened last time you know continuous
deployment I used to work with a guy
whose mantra was if it hurts do it more
you know we're scared to deploy to
production right
dude tomorrow and the day after and the
day after even if there's nothing to
deploy we'll do it over and over and
over again and the way to validate this
process is you put a kind of like a
software tracer bullet right through it
go onto your some obscure page like the
contact us or the terms and conditions
on your website and see if you can add a
comment at the bottom of that page that
just says verified and the date what
does it take to get that comment to come
out the other end of that release
processor you can see it on a public
facing web page in some organizations
that could take months you want to get
that down as tight as you can if you can
get it down to minutes that's brilliant
get it down to the point where you just
check it in to get and there it is a
couple of seconds later you're
absolutely winning because one you want
to change something you can get feedback
really quickly two if you need to roll
back because something behaved in an
unexpected way it's also very easy it
gives you confidence it gives you trust
it helps you develop understanding now
one of the interesting things that I've
noticed about legacy systems is how
cutting-edge they were when they seemed
like a good idea is directly related to
how easy it is to keep them alive
there's a bunch of code that I wrote for
spotlight back when friends was on TV
which is in classic ASP using jscript
and comm objects do you know how you run
classic ASP on Windows Server 2016 you
tick this box it is still there all of
that code literally you can copy and
paste and we'll run right now on an
Amazon ec2 instance running Windows
Server 2016
because classic ASP got to a point of
maturity where it was absolutely as
baked into the operating system and
Microsoft is very very good going we're
not gonna break stuff that people have
paid money for apart from Zune I'm sorry
about that but you know and so classic
ASP still works and because of that we
lose the understanding of what exactly
is involved in doing it do any of you
know how the brake light on your car
works you push them you know pedal the
light comes on yeah and one day you push
a pedal and the light doesn't come on
and a couple of days after that someone
tells you about it those are interesting
days but do you actually deal
know anything about how to maintain the
system do you know how to install it do
you know how to make changes to it do
you think this person knows how to
maintain the brake light system on their
car the stuff that people are good at
maintaining is the stuff that doesn't
work and a lot of the time the legacy
code the stuff was scared to change the
reason twe scared to change it is that
it actually works pretty well
it's in production it's it's purring
away smoothly no one can remember how it
got there or what it's doing while it's
there but it's live and the money is
coming in and people are buying things
and you know making movies or selling
airline tickets or whatever it is that
your organization is doing and so we
have this kind of weird situations of
stuff where you very rapidly get
familiarity is often the stuff which is
not terribly good in the first place the
stuff which surprises you is when
someone's like the system's down you're
like I didn't even know we had that
system and they're like yeah made us a
couple of million quid last year you're
like really I didn't know about it yet
it never broke just kind of put away
quietly like the brake light here on
your BMW and so one of the most valuable
techniques we can use to promote
understanding of these kinds of systems
is transparency we want to go into the
the systems which are working the ones
that everyone has kind of forgotten that
they're even there and we want to say
well what are they doing you know I
always loved the fact in Star Trek The
Next Generation the engine is part of
the set there is this huge thing in the
middle now I I happen to know because
it's inside a show business knowledge
that the engine here is an ultraviolet
disco light in a tank full of gin and
tonic because that's what gives it that
was how they got that blue that
Cherenkov radiation effect on on TV
shows and stuff but you know this was
part of the set and if you ever watched
Star Trek The Next Generation and you
saw the engine room and this thing was
not glowing blue you knew exactly what
was going on and that that was the plot
of this episode is the enterprise is
crippled the engines are down what's
happened why isn't it glowing what
happened to the gin and tonic you know
there's a problem here we want to try
and create the same you know level of
transparency and awareness you have
these systems that never go wrong
put sitting on the equivalent of you
know dashboard lights on your car is the
stock control system working of course
it's working it's been working for 10
years yes but is it work
today is the first indicator we have
that there's a problem and the capacity
of it and we wait to get an angry phone
call are we about to run out of database
space you know we have legacy systems
where someone put them in place 10 years
ago they work perfectly
one day someone decommissioned the email
that would tell you if it was running
out of disk space and it's just sitting
there quietly logging a couple of
transactions a day to a C Drive which
has I don't know 64 gigs of capacity as
that was a lot back in the days when we
provision these kinds of systems and you
know I think a big part of this we as an
industry have to accept some collective
responsibility for the challenges that
we face because during certainly during
the 1980s and 1990s the kind of first
wave of business software and business
software automation we as an industry
went around telling people buy computers
get a paperless office integrate
everything you can fire all of your
staff and you can run your entire
company from this one room we have one
button and you we push it for you before
your home you know we sold this prospect
of business automation being this
magical you know we automate all of the
processes and then it just it runs by
magic and we as much as anybody are
responsible for this idea of software
projects like you know a project which
has a start and a finish and then after
it's finished the problem is solved and
it's fine you know
it's we've built something and once the
thing is built it just runs forever and
this is why we encounter this friction
in organizations where they're like why
do we have 20 software engineers on
payroll we are not a software company we
sell tires and you're like you don't
sell tires the software sells tires you
know your job is finding people you can
plug into the software and the 20
engineers are there because every time
you find a person then know exactly like
the people who were involved in the case
study when you wrote the thing in the
first place you know you look at any
kind of classic textbook on on business
automation and something that will we'll
come across a lot is manual processes
have flexibility in them
you know you're going to say check into
a hotel you're like I'm allergic to
carrots they're like no problem they
make a note on the menu they send that
through to the kitchen the chef looks at
it like okay no carrots for you that's
fine you go to a Hertz on that as an
iPad touchscreen you like room this
phone must occurred where's the allergic
to carrots but
it doesn't exist so you're like I have
an allergy to carrots and they're like
oh hang on let me see there's no button
I looked you know and that kind of
flexibility when you automate a process
what you do is you automate one person
or at one team's snapshot of how that
process worked on one particular day
when you captured that set of
requirements and this is changing people
are getting used to the idea you know
agile lean and Kanban have played a big
part in this and like it you don't tell
us what you want and then we ship it you
tell us what you want now we'll give it
to you tomorrow you tell us what you
want the day after that and we'll keep
going around that process for as long as
it takes or we'll come back as often as
is necessary so that you can keep
evolving you can keep developing the
things that you're doing it's not easy
keeping track of all the stuff you know
because we have this perception of you
know software breaks we got to monitor
it we've got to do this we got to invest
in maintaining it we've got to invest in
keeping the whole thing running and a
lot of the times you look at
organizations and you think your
accounting model here maybe isn't quite
right you've got 20 software engineers
on staff who are maintaining a system
that you cannot actually track the value
streams through this organization and
work out whether you're selling enough
tires I'm using tires as a hypothetical
example by the way that you don't know
whether you're selling enough tires to
cover that you just know that the
software is important because that's
what you were told you have to sell
tires because that's what you do and if
you don't have the engineers the
software will stop working and you will
have legacy code incidents but often the
most valuable thing that you can do is
you can look at a system you go this
doesn't make sense anymore
this should no longer be here let's
start trimming away some of the fat some
of the unnecessary you'll upset some
customers you know I had a situation
once where we wanted to upgrade a
front-end on a page a feature on one of
our websites and we're kind of digging
through the logs and it's like we got
five people who are still using build of
Firefox that wouldn't work on it and
we're like ok how long's it gonna take
to make all this stuff work in Firefox
build 38 or whatever it was it was like
a couple of weeks I was like what's it
gonna cost to get a couple of bottles of
really good single malt scotch and we'll
send someone to each of those people be
like hello we're from spotlight we
brought your bottle of whiskey and we're
gonna upgrade
your computer while you drink it you
know just think of other ways of solving
the problem ways of eliminating moving
the complexity out of the codebase maybe
you just decide we're not doing that
anymore the eight people who use this
feature are gonna be upset and they
might you know say nasty things about us
on Twitter but we can do that where
grown-ups here we can handle a little
bit of controversy because this is the
right decision for what we are doing
think about a definition of done the
code is deleted the github repositories
are archived the database is offline the
servers are decommissioned the teams at
the beach drinking beers this is the
software system that is not going to
wake you up at 4 o'clock on Sunday
morning this is what a finished software
project actually looks like we must have
the confidence the trust the
understanding and the control that are
necessary to go into the code and say
this is the right thing to do you know
and the world that we live in today
it runs on software software it's
absolutely everywhere we cannot get away
from it we cannot rewrite it we don't
know what it does we can't switch it off
we're relying on it so like I said you
know book our train tickets and sell us
tires and washer dryers and all of the
things that we rely on day after day
after day and the vast majority of the
code that runs the world is legacy code
it is VB and it's Excel spreadsheets and
it's dotnet web forms that was written
before people really knew how to do unit
testing properly we need to get better
at how we'd cope with it writing code is
fun you know downhill invention it's
brilliant you sit there with your little
feedback loop on your mental model and
it's an incredibly rewarding exercise
and that's brilliant for prototyping for
R&D for experiments for validating new
concepts and all kinds of things but all
of the time the way that we actually
create the most value the way that we
change the world we live in is not
inventing new stuff it is by helping us
and the people around us get better at
working with all the stuff that already
exists and may be the solution to legacy
code has been staring us in the face
this whole time because what we need to
do is control it bring it into a sandbox
get confident alter it get to a point
where we know how to make changes and
eventually when the time is right and
the understanding is there delete it
thank you very much
we have a few minutes for questions I
believe which might mean somebody comes
running around with a microphone or
might not I don't know okay are there
any questions or have we achieved total
enlightenment cool well thank you all
very much for coming
I'm around all day come and chat if you
want to talk about legacy code or
made-up programming languages or any of
that kind of stuff I don't kind of pub
conf
yeah but I see you today I see a pop gun
if not I'll see you next time thanks a
lot have a good day